dude semi-related i started
a show on netflix
it's called undercover it's a dutch show
or something or something
okay um it's dubbed i like it a lot you
should check it out dude what's it
called
undercover okay what's it about uh
it's basically it's about some town in
in
uh scandinavia i forget where
but they produce a lot of ecstasy there
okay
so this series is based on real events
of two people going undercover
living part-time or living casually next
to
the head of it all and trying to get
into his life
and you know so far i'm liking it some
parts are on the nose but
it's a it's an enjoyable series what why
is it
that so much ecstasy is produced there
i mean dutch people men they're just
dead they just like to do it that's why
they make so much do it
yeah yeah where else are we gonna get it
when dutch police go to seize drugs and
they see his ecstasy they
they they pass some back they just divvy
up the bag they say well we take
too fresh and they're all bogged
and then you take the rest of this and
then
and then the people they're arresting
get the drugs back i know they get the
drugs back
they get the drugs back so that they can
take the drugs in prison so that the
time
and the dutch prison can pass right
better right right yeah yeah that makes
sense
what is it what is a dutch prison anyway
um
making making clogged shoes no
that's too much labor oh okay yeah
it's probably just chilling just i mean
clearly
we saw we saw asaps
dude that's my dorm dude wasn't that in
sweden
sweden scandinavia yeah that's all it's
all close right
i remember there's a people kept talking
about this one ecstasy producer
[ __ ] what was his name wait hold up
thinking about ecstasy producers
like actual producers is just so funny
it literally was like that he had a
brain yeah it was um
what was it he made the orange teslas
you ever heard of those
let's just google it the most famous
actors
they had the tesla logo on them
and um and this guy's name was cp
cp yeah hold on let me google that real
quick
i just searched who produced orange
tesla mdma
elon musk elon's an idiot he did tequila
he should have just sold
mdma orange
the whole drug underworld has profited
off my brand for years and it's time for
me to take it back so i've created my
own
ecstasy and with the new tesla autopilot
you can take the ecstasy on the highway
and you don't have to worry about
crashing into anyone and you can
absolutely
roll your tits off i mean um without
having to worry also covet is fake
also covid is fake indeed
you see that tweet that was like i just
took two pcr tests
or four pcr tests two of them were
negative two of them are positive
something bogus is going on here
it's like it's it's so funny that the
way
he just does not tweet like a
billionaire the way rich people tweet
about covid
is the same way we act when we get a
parking ticket
or when we get pulled over it's so funny
they're like oh dude
i took my thing and like
i don't know how i got it there's no way
there's no way yeah yeah
this sucks
this [ __ ] blows man i gotta stay
inside for a week
so lame dude
um yeah but i don't it's just funny like
the way that elon
he just tweets his thoughts you know
yeah something's weird something weird
is going on here
and you're like you know how many people
trust your word like
god like how many 14 year olds now that
think
coveted testing is rigged because you
just tweeted that
that's that's why he does it man yeah
elon wants to be more celebrity than he
does
uh a tech guy anymore he's he's
transcended being the smart guy
now he just wants to be the hot
smart rich guy yeah i mean yeah i think
that's what he always wanted to be
bet you he leaks his nudes yeah
i think he's gonna do something weird
like that like a like a
like a pornhub tape is gonna come out no
like not that
not that great yeah
what i feel like he would just tweet a
picture of
grimes with pasties on covering her
hoo-ha
standing in front of him and he'd be
like regular sunday
quarantine going just right
man i just got a visceral thought of him
clapping grimes as [ __ ]
oh god no
his surprise ass belly button
gross dude hit the [ __ ] the surprised
emoji
front dad bod that he has just two tiny
nipples and his
big old belly button like just bouncing
off her lower back
jesus christ
[Laughter]
oh lord
[Laughter]
i pretty much saw that man remember i
know
dude the 180 you did there i'll never
forget
because i remember just taking it out in
person i saw grimes and elon musk
making out in person i saw that and
that's a real
story and i turned around and noel and i
was like
[Applause]
part of me i kind of feel like if they
would have
seen me see them like grimes would have
come over
or maybe elon would have come over and
be like come come here son come here
you just you try you're not supposed to
and he grabs me by the hair like this
and holds me up and grimes
slits my throat and you gotta watch me
just
bleed out all over the world no i
picture he'd just come up to you and be
like you try and then he makes out with
you
and then grimes is just watching with a
big ass smile
no grimes comes over there and she's all
like maybe she tries seducing us
what is this some sort of group sex
thing and then she goes in like this
and just sucks the soul out of our
bodies
[Laughter]
just hands us two orange teslas cp's my
best friend
cp that's the guy's name if anyone knows
any any more info on this guy
cp on the on the tabs he was
the he he was the most famous ecstasy
producer i'm pretty sure
and then stopped once 911 happened or
something like that i forget what
happened
is there is there like a silk road
youtube
for drug production where it's like you
know a beat tutorial
it's like some 17 year old kid in the
suburbs yell it up
[Laughter]
it's your boy hot bars um just gonna
teach y'all how to press xanax
super straightforward i bet you there is
man
not cutting with fent that shit's so
whack dude [ __ ] fan
[ __ ] fan forever um
anyways dog so yeah i'm going to go
ahead and get it started
so first going to start like sodium
nitrate
[Music]
it's just this go what are you saying
no just like this lazy ass tutorial it's
like like the cuts are all bad
added this add that yeah add potassium
typically me i like to cut a little bit
of inositol in my xanax because i feel
you don't really
need the full xanax no it's only
a little bit this is a tick tock that's
what it is it's a super fast-paced tick
tock tutorial yeah
what's up today i'm going to teach you
how to make denix
comment if you want more comment what
you want to see next
look at what i sent to the talking
points that's that's the ultimate
ecstasy pills right there branded with
the reddit logo
yes dude this guy was posting it on
reddit
a picture of accuracy with the reddit
logo brandon he says beautiful little
[ __ ] aren't they
unreal unreal
my favorite press they're closer to 250
but same diff
very available in socal and bay area
cp reddits are my favorite press by far
isn't this crazy dude that's such an
unfortunate
sentence that someone's going to cut out
of context right there oh yeah
see it's an awful brand name it's just
an awful acronym never use that for
anything
cody's and now welcome to cody cp hour
you